exploring our cosmic origins is our
motto
the really primary thing that alma
allows us to probe
is
the early stages of pretty much
everything you can think of in
the universe it allows us to probe the
birth of galaxies
the birth of stars the birth of planets
in chile there's a really powerful
telescope
it captures images from space in detail
that has never been achieved before
i love data and every one of the images
from alma can surprise you can show
features that really change the way
people think about that area of science
alma is comprised of 66 individual
telescopes which are all brought
together to act as a single telescope to
produce a single image of a region of
the sky
what we've done is build lots of little
telescopes that are 12 meter in size
and we distribute them so that they're
10 kilometers apart
and we have lots of antennas because the
more that you fill in that area the
better the sensitivity of your images
will be
we can now look back to
times that are equivalent to 11 or 12
billion years ago in the history of our
universe it's very likely that alma is
going to tell us about the
birth of galaxies the alma correlator is
basically the supercomputer so it brings
in all the signals it has the equivalent
of 16 million pcs the thing excites me
the most about alma is the discoveries
that's made in how planets are formed
the data that we get from the telescope
the raw data the size is often in the
range of several hundred gigabytes to a
terabyte
but once we synthesize that information
down into an image
it will be about the size of four or
five megapixels what you could do on a
camera phone
by knowing how the solar system form we
can have a better idea of where we came
from and maybe where we're going in the
distant future
you